[Música]
aquí comienza el debate de france 24 fue
rechazado el texto de la nueva
constitución chilena este domingo 13
millones de ciudadanos votaron y un
abrumador 62% dijo no a la que prometía
ser la carta magna más progresista de
américa latina y que convertiría al
estado chileno en un garante de más de
100 de derechos la derecha y algunos
sectores de la izquierda la clasificaron
de sectorizada y de no atacar el bloqueo
político en el país porque fracasó la
campaña de aprobación lo discutiremos en
unos minutos precisamente para analizar
este tema hemos invitado a guillermo
holzmann analista político
internacionalista y a roberto cárcamo
analista y académico de la universidad
de mayor ambos bienvenidos y a nuestros
televidentes les recuerdo que ustedes
también hacen parte de esta conversación
dejen sus preguntas y comentarios en
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
twitter instagram y facebook en donde
nos encuentran como france24 bajo ese
hierro ángel ago efe 24 me cuenta
personaje la etiqueta es numeral el d
efe 24 en youtube pueden seguir nuestra
señal en streaming y también saludamos a
las personas que nos escuchan en nuestro
podcast los invito para que escuchen
todos los contenidos de nuestro programa
de que está disponible en app el podcast
spotify deezer y tuning
el descontento expresado durante el
estallido social de 2019 quedó en pausa
con la caída del proceso empezado por
manifestantes y cuyo momento cúlmen era
el plebiscito la carta magna- se centró
en los derechos sociales el medio
ambiente la paridad de género y en los
derechos de los indígenas pero ahora
tendrá que ser replanteada o al menos
así lo ha prometido el gobierno de
gabriel boliche que ya se vio obligado a
hacer cambios en el gabinete con sólo
seis meses en el poder el reporte
inicial es de ariana villacorta
por una aplastante mayoría los chilenos
rechazaron el texto que durante un año
elaboró una convención constitucional
para reemplazar a la vigente desde la
dictadura de augusto pinochet esta
decisión de los chilenos y chilenas
exige a nuestras instituciones y actores
políticos que trabajemos con más empeño
con más diálogo con más respeto y cariño
hasta arribar a una propuesta que nos
interpreta a todos que de confianza que
nos una como país la vigente carta
magna- seguirá rigiendo aunque el
presidente de chile gabriel boric ya
anunció que convocará un nuevo proceso
constituyente y que se cumplirá con el
mandato del plebiscito de octubre de
2020 en el que casi el 80% de los
chilenos pidió un cambio constitucional
la verdad es que esta constitución del
80 yo estaba bastante
mala porque solamente defiende los
grandes poderes y nos dejan a nosotros
los pueblo originarios fuera sin embargo
este resultado muestra que el apoyo de
la población ha disminuido debido a la
preocupación por ciertas propuestas
controversias que involucran a los
constituyentes elegidos para redactarla
sí
no teníamos
estos resultados junto a la crisis
inflacionaria y de seguridad supone un
duro golpe para el gobierno de boris
pues esta votación pese a que no se
trata de una elección a un cargo público
es vista como una evaluación de su
gestión con este telón de fondo vamos a
comenzar con esta conversación y voy a
dar inicio con guillermo holzmann
analista político e internacionalista
guillermo gracias a usted la que iba a
hacer en la nueva constitución de los
chilenos fue tachada de sectorizada o
incluso demasiado progresista porque que
fue lo que falló en la balanza de este
proyecto que inició con un apoyo
ciudadano sin precedentes y que prometía
además ser uno de los procesos más
transformadores en la américa latina
actual
catalán yo la verdad es que el 87 por
ciento del padrón electoral que concurre
a votar y le da un 62 por ciento de
rechazo a la revuelta constitucional hay
varias razones para explicar este
rechazo en primer lugar la desconfianza
respecto a todo el proceso y la forma en
que se encaminó durante un año con altos
y bajos pero dónde de la confusión era
bastante evidente lo segundo los temas
de este progresismo maximalista que se
plantea dentro de la constitución y que
deja muchas ambigüedades los tema de la
plurinacionalidad por ejemplo en
términos de autogobierno y autonomía en
términos de un sistema judicial separado
del resto del país para el 2 para un 12%
de los pueblos originarios que es una
cantidad que tiene el chile de estas
etnias en definitiva y va generando
mucha más mucha más desconfianza también
se suma eso de todo el ambiente que se
está viviendo en términos de seguridad y
de necesidades económicas en virtud de
los efectos la pandemia y lo que son hoy
día el impacto de la invasión rusa a
ucrania a eso también se suman el señor
de la deficiencia de la propia
constitución al nuevo mencionar los
partidos políticos en general un auto de
un autogobierno bien digo mucho más
potente en términos de autonomía a nivel
local y a nivel regional
y una serie de otros temas que sumándose
y finalmente lleva a que mucha gente que
no iba a votar normalmente y considerase
la aprobación que se hace en octubre del
año 2020 y definitivamente no con este
resultado no estaba cumpliendo la
espectativa ciudadana
además hay analistas en el país que han
dicho que los ciudadanos estaban
abrumados ante los contenidos tan
amplios del nuevo texto y algunos
incluso los calificaron de arbolito de
navidad por prometer todo para todos
pero sin ser lo suficientemente
aterrizado usted que opina roberto
cárcamo
hola qué tal muchas gracias por la
invitación
la verdad la constitución o el texto la
propuesta de nueva constitución que fue
rechazada es verdad que contiene varias
innovaciones varias novedades
y
por las condiciones en que se dio su
elaboración su debate recoge las
peticiones de múltiples sectores
sin necesariamente priorizar lo uno
podría explicar la sala la técnica de
concierto que se redactó pero el injusto
me parece señalar que es un árbol de
navidad o que le falta concreción las
constituciones en general son textos
normativos
pero con un lenguaje abiertos y llenas
de principios que deben ser concretados
por la legislación por la jurisprudencia
eso no es una particularidad del texto
que se rechazó en comparación a otras
constituciones ahora bien en su opinión
que falló entonces
yo creo que la
propuesta de nueva constitución
puso énfasis en algunos aspectos con la
discusión se centró en algunos aspectos
que son de interés de
cierta parte de la academia de ciertos
sectores minoritarios
pero que al ser tan ensalzados en el
debate y particularmente por la campaña
del rechazo no lograron identificar a la
gran mayoría de la población en otras
palabras el estallido social básicamente
y las ediciones que se escuchaban en la
calle eran peticiones sociales de
prestaciones sociales y no tanto de el
sistema de descentralización que opta la
constitución en una propuesta como
particularmente la forma en que se busca
solucionar el problema de la
multiculturalidad del país
ahora hay otro tema acá y es que el
presidente boris no solamente fue
elegido en medio de una ola de muchísimo
optimismo después del levantamiento
social de 2019 sino que además del
mandatario que se ha convertido en un
símbolo de esa renovación que busca el
país pues también e imprimió todo su
capital político en ese nuevo proyecto
de constitución y entonces ahora
quisiera preguntarles a ambos qué pasa
con ese capital político como se ve
comprometido de ahora en adelante y
cuando boliche lleva apenas seis meses
en el poder
la verdad
y el rechazo un sentido por ciento hay
también una derrota política para el
gobierno efectivamente el gobierno debe
distinguir en lo personal que sumó la
campaña de la pruebo y de hecho muchas
de las acciones que le correspondían
como gobierno estos seis meses quedaron
y a paso lento esperando una prueba
mayoritario quien le diese la
posibilidad de un mayor despliegue para
poder arremeter con sus con su programa
de transformación que había prometido a
al país al ser electo como presidente de
steele en esa perspectiva entonces el
presidente no solamente ahora asume esa
derrota sino que también va marcando una
línea institucional que comprende la
invitación a los partidos políticos
conversar con la cama de diputados con
el senado como lo ha hecho en hasta 48
horas y a su vez también sumar y un
proceso constituyente y va a tener
prácticas va a tener la inclusión de
pueblo originario pero conforme al 12%
todo lo que ellos representan dentro de
y lo visitó de salida como se base de
eso en la negociación por los partidos
políticos es decir con las instituciones
políticas de una república democrática
allí eso es lo que el presidente ahora
tiene la necesidad imperiosa de
demostrar que su liderazgo y su
capacidad de conducción es capaz de
llevar adelante ese proceso con
credibilidad y generar confianza para la
población pero también demostrar quién
posee una gestión gubernamental donde se
inserta el cambio de gabinete que acaba
de realizar en el día de hoy y que va
orientado a vuelva de realizar también
la reforma legislativa donde tiene un
principio importante de educación salud
entre mí no una reforma tributaria en
término una reforma de seguridad no cnc
viene ese ámbito el presidente yo diría
quién queda y que hemos sometido a una
presión que necesariamente va a tener
que dar respuesta en forma adecuada y
eso va a definir la gobernabilidad de
todo este proceso de aquí en adelante
roberto
si
el presidente está en una posición
compleja porque a la vez tiene que
definir como el gobierno busca impulsar
el proceso constituyente o retomarlo y
por el otro lado tiene que gobernar y
avanzar en su agenda legislativa
el país se ve en las encuestas es una
gran preocupación en el último tiempo la
seguridad pública tiene algunos índices
que se han deteriorado pero por otro
lado la relación con el congreso
nacional no ha sido la mejor es el
congreso más fragmentado que hemos
tenido desde el retorno de la democracia
lo cual lo hace más difícil el trato que
tiene con el gobierno y como decía el
que guillermo el cambio de gabinete más
pendiente de ambas cosas tanto a incluir
mejor una mejor relación con los
partidos políticos que lo apoyan como a
tener una mejor relación con el congreso
nacional que le permita gobernar y ahí
es importante el cambio de ministro y
son la secretaria general de la
presidencia
el ministro saliente yo creo que ya son
que comparte su trayectoria su origen en
el movimiento estudiantil que ha tenido
hasta ahora más la relación con los
parlamentarios es haber sido
parlamentario el mismo y es de esperar
que la nueva ministra de 6-3 le permita
al gobierno mejorar esa relación y esa
performance en su agenda el ejecutivo
esto es de cara a que le tenga más
gobernabilidad y de cara a que se pueda
confirmar una nueva convención una nueva
constituyente en el mejor de los casos y
que se pueda rehacer este camino hacia
una constitución que se ha hecho en
democracia y que deje atrás esta
constitución de dictadura en la época de
pinochet se van los ministros de minas
de energía y de salud entre otros como
ustedes ya mencionaron porque esos
ministerios de guillermo y será
suficiente para que boliche adquiera más
gobernabilidad y digamos de gusto a
otros partidos
poniendo pensar que en los ministerios
sectoriales como hacen los de mina salud
y otros en definitiva tienen bienes por
los avances que habían logrado con la
capacidad del diálogo tanto con los
interlocutores que le corresponden como
a ellos pero también y tienen que vivir
por la relación al interior del propio
gabinete y creo que ahí ellos salen más
unidos por un efecto
de cara de carambola más que por el
resultado del plebiscito este domingo lo
que es realmente importante es la
secretaria general d ciencia como hace
lado roberto y el ministerio del
interior y es ahí donde se produce
primero la incorporación de glück y hoy
día se denomina este organismo
democrático y que corresponde a figuras
de la concertación que gobernó chile
entre el año 1990 no cierto atrás donde
hasta el 2016 y quienes sembró la
práctica hoy día tienen una
responsabilidad de darle apoyo y sostén
político al gobierno para conseguir la
mayoría en el congreso a raíz de una paz
por llamarlo muy suavemente y de una
improvisación que se produce uno tiene
que hacer gabinete llega a las y la
presidencia mayoría ana lya uriarte que
estuvo como jefe de gabinete de michelle
bachelet que ahora estaba apoyando
directamente a la ministra interior
saliente y que llega ahí para poder
tener ese diálogo con el congreso con
todo yo diría que los cambios son
insuficientes para puede entender de que
el apruebo no ganó en ninguna parte del
país e incluso en la cárcel perdió
perdió en los dos lugares o hasta los
pueblos originarios entonces da la
impresión de que se requería una y un
cambio de gabinete un tanto más profundo
el discurso del presidente una vez que
termina la parte formal del cambio
gabinete es bastante claro en determinar
de que ellos tienen la legitimidad del
gobierno y esa legitimidad del gobierno
está asociada a la votación sacada en la
segunda vuelta es decir lo que lo llevó
a la presidencia y prescinde en la
práctica del resultado del plebiscito al
cual solamente se respira en el último
párrafo este cambio gabinete y eso para
decir que se va a acabar trabajando en
ello pero si lo gradúa el énfasis de
presidente ahora es que si él hace cosas
y la hacen bien que fue lo que le pidió
a sus ministros en el metro entrantes va
a aumentar la aprobación en la opinión
pública al elevado line al gobierno iba
a separarse de todo el de toda la
convivencia en el fondo que todavía
anteriormente al lado del proceso
constitucional y en el apoyo de la
prueba bueno usted lo dijo al principio
y guillermo que esta semana va a ser una
semana crucial en la que el presidente
va a tener que demostrar que tanto es
capaz de sacrificar y que cambio se
puede orientar para obtener más apoyo y
más gobernabilidad en ese camino esos
sacrificios que ya comenzó a hacer
implican su círculo de confianza su base
de gobierno personas con las que él
pretendía mostrar por ejemplo esta
fuerza de su gabinete paritario y de los
derechos por las mujeres en su círculo
de confianza con las personas que lo
acompañaron y que también fueron líderes
durante las marchas estudiantiles
[Música]
usted roberto
piensa que esto debilita de alguna
manera ahora pues esta base del gobierno
planteado por boris ahora que tiene que
hacer cambios que son forzados que
llegan tan pronto y que además
probablemente no serán suficientes
tendrán que seguir las negociaciones de
cara a obtener esa aprobación que le
faltó día y hacer eso esas enmiendas o
esos cambios en el proyecto de nueva
constitución
puede ser vamos a ver el primero una
aclaración en general la ministra de
minería sigue en el cargo de la
sobreviviente pero puede ser eso es un
hecho que tendrá que verse pero para
ponerlo en contexto respecto del proceso
constituyente en sí lo que tiene que
definirse es particularmente delicado
porque por ejemplo si me miento que
tengamos en este momento fijo para
continuar con el proceso constituyente
lo que tenemos es
presidentes de partidos de oposición que
han señalado y tienden continuar con el
proceso y salvo un partido republicano
que está más a la derecha
señales de que hay un
orden en la derecha que todavía está en
construcción frente a un resultado que
todavía les sorprende decir que van o
que nos van a reunirse con el presidente
finalmente la reunión va
entonces hay básicamente tres
alternativas en el supuesto desde el
proceso continuo
se realiza una nueva elección de
convencionales
eso requiere una reforma constitucional
a la actual constitución la del 80 que
tiene tantas reformas y en el sentido de
permitir un nuevo proceso pero eso puede
ser en el primer caso con las mismas
reglas de los que tuvimos en reglas de
elección de los convencionales de la
convención que tuvimos que hace poco y
lo que yo creo es lo más probable que la
derecha se siente y no bueno vamos a
tener un nuevo proceso pero con reglas
electorales distintas
probablemente con variedad pero con una
distinta forma de integrar a los pueblos
originarios de los escaños reservados
que tenían una particular forma de
integrarse y en particular sin listas de
independientes eso fue una innovación el
sistema proporcional con un sistema
electoral done pero con listas de
independientes e independientes que se
integraron a la convención pero que
rápidamente se desordenaron porque no
tenían mayor lealtad entre ellos y
tenían muchos objetivos común
la segunda alternativa es que la
propuesta de nueva constitución surja de
alguna forma de debate parlamentario
podría ser mediante el reinicio del
trámite del proyecto de constitución que
dejó michelle bachelet al terminar su
gobierno que viniera paradiso podría ser
que el congreso a llamarse alguna
comisión técnica que lo asesorará y eso
depende de la discusión que se dé en el
seno del congreso ahí es bastante
delicado
[Música]
como el congreso en le tomé el pulso a
su propia legitimidad a la propia
situación del país el congreso es un
órgano que hoy en día no está está
bastante de legitimado y bastante
desconfianza a través de la encuesta y
por lo tanto hay que ver ahora
derechamente lo que tú preguntabas es
similar el porcentaje de aprobación en
las últimas encuestas tiene presidente
boris con el porcentaje que obtuvo la
prueba no necesariamente se cruzan ambas
cifras pero es un buen indicio de que la
votación del aprobó es más o menos la
votación y fue el porcentaje de
población que está actualmente apoyando
al gobierno por lo tanto el que el
presidente no haya lizio el giro
y realice un cambio de hoja de ruta
tratando de abrirse hacia el centro del
espectro político es probablemente
signifique un desangramiento de su apoyo
por la izquierda pero que no sea tan
significativo como la ganancia que puede
tener tanto para el resto de su gestión
como para un eventual proceso
constituyente que está por comenzar y
ahí la pregunta entonces pasando ya a
guillermo sería si estas acciones que
están por venir van a deslegitimar el
levantamiento del 2019 que nos llevó
hasta este punto que debía ser el punto
culmen el punto en el que chile por fin
podía haber un cambio después de meses y
meses de protestas después de 30
fallecidos y después de víctimas de
violencia policial se deslegitima y si o
sea hay un proceso de legitimación y por
lo tanto parte una parte de esos grupos
que estaban en la calle protestando y
exigiendo que la desigualdad debería
calificarse y hacer un cambio
estructural dentro del estado de chile
varios grupos no van a estar de acuerdo
con lo que vaya a hacer el presidente
bonito
a una esquema de negociación con los
partidos tradicionales
buscando una salida para una nueva
constitución eso va a significar que el
gobierno de boris como seguir la
coalición que lo apoya deberá ser capaz
de mantener diálogos y mantener una
influencia sobre estos grupos para poder
sumarlos a un esfuerzo que va a tener un
resultado porque efectivamente en el
nuevo proceso constitucional muchos los
temas que se abordaron yo fueron balas
bordados en este proceso van a estar
también en la mesa es decir ya el tema
que se han visibilizado respecto a
recibimos respecto a vanidades respecto
a los clientes de respecto a derechos
sociales entonces respecto a la
descentralización es decir hay una
cantidad de temas que necesariamente se
van a abordar igualmente pero no de la
forma en que quedaron resueltos en el
proceso constituyente entonces ahí en
euro que hay un tema el presidente boris
ideal de legitimarse un poco y alejarse
de las de los elementos centrales de su
programa va a tener que lidiar también
con los elementos internos de esos
llamaba roberto pero también con todos
los grupos de jóvenes que buscaban más
no deja de ser interesante adquirir la
votación de jóvenes fue mucho mayor que
lo que se esperaba a favor del rechazo
que de la prueba y eso también hay que
hay que entender de que hay una
evolución social y hay una situación
dentro del país que es necesario
comprender y que probablemente no
estamos entendiendo completamente y eso
también me permite angela y decir que el
rechazo no tiene dueño
y el no tener dueño le deja muchas
oportunidades tanto al gobierno y
particularmente al presidente boris pero
también a los partidos políticos para
participar en un proceso legitimarse
frente a una sociedad que critica
permanentemente y no le devalúa bien y
por lo tanto ahí yo diría si uno ve el
vaso medio lleno hay oportunidades para
todos pero va a depender claramente el
cómo se comporte en estos días iban a
ser los funcionales para saber y cultiva
social a futuro pues un poco lo que se
insinúa en el guillermo y roberto es lo
que ustedes han dicho de que
probablemente este nuevo proceso de
convención incluiría más actuación de
los diputados más actuaciones del
legislativo y ahí le pregunto a usted
roberto hay voluntad política para que
este nuevo proceso avance y para que no
se quede estancado de una vez más
puede abrirla al menos desde los
partidos que forman la mayor coalición
de posición desde chile vamos se han
dado señales de que existe la voluntad
ahora seguramente y van a poner sus
condiciones
con todo chile es un sistema
presidencial
y en esa tradición de presidencialismo
que no se cambiaba en la
propuesta de nueva constitución seguía
siendo un sistema muy presidencial que
se proponía la iniciativa la tiene
presidente que sería un error por parte
del presidente de la república delegar
totalmente en el congreso nacional en
los partidos oficialistas representados
en el congreso nacional la iniciativa
sobre cómics en el proceso porque eso lo
va a generar mayor desorden en un
congreso muy fragmentado
ahí existe la posibilidad
de que si el presidente no toma
definiciones pronto respecto de qué y
cómo seguir con el proceso caigamos en
un parlamentarismo de facto y un
parlamentarismo de facto bastante
desordenado porque tenemos cámaras de
comunicación nacional muy fragmentadas y
tanto es así el síntoma que lo que
grafica bien que el presidente está en
este momento y apoyado por dos
coaliciones de partido socialistas no
por una no no ha logrado generar
siquiera una sola coalición
antes del cambio de gabinete y día de
las señales que se leen en que la prensa
ahora mismo está escribiendo está
hablando en la radio es bueno que una
condición ganó frente a la otra siempre
es opinable siempre es discutible en
este momento la iniciativa a diferencia
de local plática algunas personas que
dicen la pelota está en la cancha del
congreso en el lado de la cancha del
congreso no la pelota la tiene el
presidente de la república y tiene que
demostrar liderazgo frente a los
partidos que le apoyan frente a los
parlamentarios que son oficialistas y
ofrecer una hoja de ruta negociada pero
una hoja de ruta clara ante la oposición
para que esto resulte sino probablemente
estos se desordenen que empiece a caer
demasiado temprano en una etapa de
pérdida de poder tal como le ocurrió a
piñera desde el estallido social bueno y
es que aquí también hay la gran pregunta
de ese si puede morir realmente en
gobernar sino una nueva constitución a
la que amarró sus propuestas y su plan
pues digamos su propuesta de país es
cuando fue elegido puede morir este
proyecto de izquierdas si no hay un
cambio de constituciones le pregunté si
firmó en julio es muy difícil que lo
pueda hacer son transformaciones
profundas son cambios en la actual
constitución son difíciles de bolívar a
cabo por la lógica que tiene pero
también por la dinámica de aprobaciones
que hay al interior en consecuencia no
teniendo la mayoría del congreso ahí
estando la fragmentación en cada uno de
los partidos y en forma transversal
dentro de los representantes
del legislativo resulta muy difícil para
volver a avanzar la única forma que
puede hacerlo sería hacer alianzas
políticas con el socialismo democrático
y también comparte un asiento tienda que
más liberal y en esa perspectiva poner
un riesgo evidente de que su apoyo en
las dos condiciones que lo soportan
tendería a disminuir ingeniería mayor
conflicto político en consecuencia el
presidente hoy día
no puede sacar solitario va a tener que
saber que está jugando un poker y
hacerlo bien puede que tenga justamente
los cuatro ases pero para tener cuatro
ases le faltan varias vueltas todavía
para por llegar a todo eso y eso yo creo
que es una forma yo diría elegante si se
quiere decir de que la gobernabilidad de
kinect y minuto es para hill que frágil
por lo que explica roberto es práctico
imponer los procesos políticos estamos
viviendo no obstante de que se han
sumado voluntades expresas antes del
plebiscito para ir a una nueva carta
fundamental en el caso de que hagan este
rechazo el tema está en que hay grupos
que están queriendo apropiarse de ese
retraso cuando eso no es posible y está
naciendo el diagnóstico errado de lo que
es esta evolución política y del propio
resultado que se obtuvo el 4 de
septiembre bueno y pongamos un ejemplo
de las propuestas que no pegaron para
este texto y pues por evidentemente que
no fueron aceptadas por ejemplo el
aborto que fue legalizado en el país
hace pocos años y sólo bajo ciertas
condiciones en unos casos específicos
iba a pasar a ser un derecho explícito
en la
cambios como este para ustedes son muy
abruptos se puede utilizar esa expresión
que algunos analistas y medios han
utilizado demasiado progresista un
cambio demasiado rápido que abrumó
demasiado a la población en el comienzo
con guillermo la verdad es que en el
caso del aborto los sectores más
conservadores del país y eso lo ven como
una suerte de
libertinaje y una cosa totalmente y que
no puede quedar instalado de esa manera
lo que es correcto es que el aborto ya
es constituye un derecho por lo menos
del punto de vista de análisis de
evolución social y democracias más
desarrolladas es un derecho pero
requiere una adecuada regulación
no es no es un derecho marc es un
derecho que ejerce por sí para así una
mujer presenta terminadas situaciones y
eso requiere regulación auxilio atención
en seguimiento acompañamiento a varias
cosas y muy estas cosas no están en la
constitución ni se colocaban como
requisito entonces ahí hay un tema donde
una cosa tan sensible como el aborto
no basta que sean que sea un derecho
tiene que tiene un marco de referencia
para aquellas personas que lo van a ser
lo asuma responsablemente la libertad
tiene un número de responsabilidades un
grado de posibilidad muy importante
entonces yo creo quien el aborto piedad
demasiado abierto también en esa
perspectiva aparecía demasiado
progresista un aborto esa circunstancia
es muy difícil sostener o sea el menos
práctico porque prácticamente existe en
la constitución no puede ser un
incentivo en el tema del aborto
descuidar justamente a la madre y
habitamos y cuidar el proceso de pre
operación también pero no dejarlo a un
libro al vertido y va en contra de la
población e incluso al estado claro pero
además el roberto están otras propuestas
controversiales como la que ha repetido
ya varias veces guillermo en este debate
y es la propuesta de definir a chile
como un estado plurinacional que los
pueblos indígenas que son apenas casi
perdón 13 por ciento de la población
puedan ser reconocidos como naciones con
sus propios sistemas de gobernanza con
sus propios tribunales los derechos a la
naturaleza está esta manera de presentar
como un sujeto de derecho a la
naturaleza a los animales de hacer
medidas ambientales que que también
digamos que se quedaron en el aire como
tendrían que ser replanteadas para que
sean aceptadas por otras partes de la
gobernanza o por otras partes de actores
políticos que sean más conservadores en
chile
habrás ya no creo que la constitución
del proyecto de constitución fuera
demasiado progresista
porque a ver en verdad en buena parte
del germen del estallido estaba en el
reclamo por cómo entienden o se
establecen buenos servicios de seguridad
social de salud o de educación que
siguió
entonces si definimos si emprendemos
progresista por ser una constitución
demasiado izquierda creo que no lo era
si es discutible si es que era y desde
el punto de vista de la convención
cuando está acordando el texto de la
constitución si es que era
estratégicamente sensato
constitucionalizar el aborto cuando era
esperable que será un punto que
resultaba incansable para una parte de
la población
la verdad no es una constitución es un
texto que fuese demasiado de izquierda
como alguna gente ha dicho que fuera
demasiado maximalista no si uno va más a
la fina desde un punto de vista jurídico
uno que puede hacer críticas a su forma
algunos aspectos técnicos hacia el
sistema político podría funcionar tal
como estaba configurado o si como
plantearon los partidos socialistas
durante la campaña había que hacer
algunas adecuaciones una vez aprobados
expo para que funcionarios de una manera
más aceitada y así era que si esta idea
de que la naturaleza tenga derechos en
lugar de ser un objeto de protección
sean las personas las que tengan
derechos medio ambiente libre de
contaminación o derecho a un equilibrio
ecológico si eso iba a afectar de alguna
manera concreta el funcionamiento del
país o de las actividades económicas
pero son discusiones se notará bastante
técnicas
la
la población y el grueso pienso yo no os
identifico con esas discusiones a veces
tan finas muy probablemente ya que me
preguntabas por eso las menciones de
guillermo el resultado al menos no
habría sido tan atrás y como si en lugar
de hablar de plurinacionalidad y la
constitución hablase de multi
interculturalidad la diferencia es más
bien sutil en la práctica puede ser muy
sentida para mucha gente pero en los
efectos en la aplicación jurídica
práctica de la constitución voy a hacer
mucho la diferencia sin embargo si uno
habla de plurinacionalidad bueno eso era
difícil de explicar para algunas
personas y difícil de entender además
que afectaba el
sentimiento de unidad nacional que como
en todos los estados latinoamericanos a
todos nosotros se nos enseña desde la
escuela resultaba un poco contra
intuitivo ahora además me
y me atrevo a meter un ingrediente más
que todo señoras entra en las comunas y
con mayor presencia indígena con mayor
población indígena fue más acentuado la
tendencia al rechazo por lo tanto la
manera en que la academia
particularmente las ciencias sociales y
ha
interpretado y el sentido y las
necesidades de los pueblos indígenas
bueno parece haber sido algo errada
hasta ahora como para haber planteado
determinada visión en el texto que se
propuso en la ciudadanía y que fuese
particularmente rechazado las comunas
como ayer población indígena bien ya nos
estamos quedando sin tiempo les quiero
pedir a ambos de 30 segundos solamente
para que me den sus conclusiones me
hicieron con esta frase porque es que
los países de américa latina están
mirando a chile con la posibilidad de
que lula da silva vuelva a gobernar
brasil como en el primer presidente
electo de izquierda en colombia gustavo
petro pues hay una tendencia que se está
moviendo ustedes como ve en el papel de
chile en los siguientes años
bueno la verdad es que el papel de esquí
le va a seguir siendo de referente ya lo
ha sido un país que aprueba mucho
constitucional y luego rechaza la
propuesta que se le presente y lo hace
en un ambiente completamente democrático
de tranquilidad creo que es una primera
ejemplo los segundos en los que los
presidentes progresistas
que vienen de la izquierda tradicional y
que han avanzado su propuesta finalmente
hoy día en el siglo 21 de 2022 2023 para
que atrapado en el pragmatismo en el
pragmatismo que depende de que está
asociado la dependencia a cada uno de
esos países y la muestra es táctil verde
está en argentina con la berta fernández
que termine asentado en el fondo
monetario a lo propio pasa con pedro
castillo más allá de la institución
interna los propios que está pasando con
petro por lo tanto el pragmatismo
político va a marcar y va de alguna
manera a frenar
el progresismo populista que muchas
veces debe asociar todos ellos y roberto
rápidamente gracias chile tiene una
larga tradición de cero país muy
legalista muy institucional
y aquí fue donde se intentó llegar al
socialismo por vía democrática con
alguien de iu así que yo confío que se
va a encontrar una salida institucional
para el problema constitucional y que va
a ser en definitiva exitoso ahora
respecto de venir del gobierno bueno el
presidente hoy tiene el desafío de poder
gobernar con la constitución vigente y
en esto no tengo tiempo de profundizar
pero difiero de guillermo que pienso que
el presidente puede desarrollar buena
parte de su programa con la constitución
vigente tiene al desafío de hacerlo y
hacerlo plausible y con el congreso que
tiene pero si es sensato si es sabio si
sabe llegar al acuerdo lo podría lograr
pues muy bien muchísimas gracias a ambos
son guillermo holzmann analista político
e internacionalista y roberto cárcamo
analista y académico de la universidad
de mayor a ustedes gracias y también a
nuestros televidentes e iu a quienes nos
sintonizan a través de nuestro sistema
de podcast sigan con nosotros nos vemos
más adelante
[Música]